and i'll tell you what leveling up is
a few years ago they started a school
not far from the olympic park a new
school anyone could send their kids to
in an area that for decades has been one
of the most disadvantaged in london
that school is brampton manor academy
and it now sends more kids to oxbridge
than eaton and if you want proof of what
i mean by unleashing potential and by
leveling up look at brampton manor and
we can do it there is absolutely no
reason why the kids of this country
should lag behind or why so many should
be unable to read or write or do basic
mathematics at 11. and to level up to
level up on top of the extra 14 billion
were put into education
on top of the increase that means every
teacher starts with a salary of thirty
thousand pounds we're announcing today a
leveling up premium of up to three
thousand pounds to send the best maths
and science teachers to the places that
need them most and above all we are
investing
we're investing in us
we're investing in our skills
skills folks our universities are world
beating i i i owe everything to my to my
tutors then they're one of the great
glories of our economy but we all know
that some of the most brilliant and
imaginative and creative people in
britain some of the best paid people in
britain
did not go to university
and to level up you need to give people
the options the skills that are right
for them and to make the most of those
skills and knowledge you need urgently
to plug all the other gaps
in the infrastructure that are still
holding people and communities back
as i've been saying over the over this
wonderful conference uh to you when i
became leader of this party there were
only can you remember what percentage of
of of uh households had gigabit
broadband when you were so kind as to
make me leader seven you've been paying
attention some of you this
seven percent only seven percent they're
absolutely right and but what will it be
by the new year
actually i'm told tonight 68
by the by the new year and thanks to
thanks to rishi's
thanks to rishi's thanks to rishi's
super deduction the pace is now
accelerating massively as companies
thrust the fiber optic vermicelli in the
most hard to reach places and
it's wonderful for years uh the snp
leader in westminster ian blackford has
been telling the commons that he is
nothing
but a humble crofter
on the isle of skye
well now that we have fiber-optic
broadband uh of of a very high quality
we can inspect the library or or is it
or is it perhaps the billiard room
urbian blackfoot's croft and that is
leveling up in action and
[Applause]
my friends
it's it's not good enough it's not good
enough just to rely on zoom after
decades of duct decisions our national
infrastructure is way behind some of our
key competitors it's a disgrace that you
still can't swiftly cross the penins by
rail the disgrace that leeds is the
largest city in europe with no proper
metro system a waste of human potential
that so many places are not served by
decent bus routes transport is one of
the supreme leveler uppers and we are
making the big generational changes
shirked by previous governments we will
do northern powerhouse rail we will link
up the cities of the midlands at the
north we will restore those sinews of
the union that have been allowed to
atrophy the a1 north of beric and on
into scotland the a75 in scotland
they're so vital for the links with with
northern ireland and the rest of the
country the north wales corridor
yes
and we will invest in our roads
unblocking those coagulated roundabouts
and steering wheel bending traffic
lights with four putting on 4 000 more
clean green buses made in this country
some of them running on hydrogen and as
we as we come out of kobe
as we come out of kobe our towns and
cities are going to be buzzing with life
because we know that a productive
workforce needs the spur that only comes
with face-to-face meetings and water
cooler gossip if young people are to
learn on the job in the way that they
always have and must we will and must
see people back in the office and that
is why
[Applause]
and that is why we are building back
better
that is why we are building back better
with a once in a century 640 billion
pound program of investment and by
making neighborhoods safer by putting in
the gigabit broadband by putting in the
roads and the schools and the healthcare
we will enable more young people
everywhere to share the dream of
homeownership the great ambition of the
human race that the left always
privately share but publicly disparage
and we can do it